is refusing to lose hope ever since she
gave birth to her twin boys 13 months
ago she's been struggling to keep them
alive
one of my twin boys fell seriously ill I
took him to the health clinic in our
village for treatment after a while they
told us they couldn't keep him there
because the illness was getting worse
and he needed to be admitted to a bigger
hospital that's why we came here in Katy
for treatment but he's still sick after
weeks of being here
doctors at this Medical Center outside
the Malian Capital say the boy is
suffering from severe malnutation he's
one of dozens of children being treated
here
child malnutrition is an age-old problem
in the country Mali is one of the
poorest in the Sahel but it has been
getting worse recently according to both
local and international organizations
on the national level we have about 200
000 children suffering from acute
malnutrition and the level of that
acuteness has surpassed all our
expectations they need to be admitted in
intensive care units and their treatment
should be paid for but there is a huge
deficit in human and financial resources
for such a task so unfortunately many of
those children lose their lives
Millions more are going hungry a number
that is growing
according to both UNICEF and wfp close
to 5 million children in this country
are in need of urgent humanitarian
assistance including in the fields of
health and nutrition
this figure shows an increase of at
least 1.5 million children in need since
2020.
relief organizations say 2 500 people
are facing famine in the Eastern region
of menaka mali's economy has been
deteriorating for years but rampant in
security has added to the misery of
millions the region of Timbuktu is being
taken over Slowly by armed groups
separatist fighters in the north have
resumed fighting after eight years of
relative peace
the U.N says Mass displacement and
restricted humanitarian access are
further complicating the situation the
imminent withdrawal of the last U.N
peacekeepers from the country at the
behest of the coup leaders is expected
to make matters worse
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera